"
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY
IS IN A TAIL SPIN.
THE BAD NEWS IS PILING UP.
DEMOCRATS ARE DIVIDED OVER HOW
TO SPEND TRILLIONS.
BIDEN'S POLL NUMBERS ARE
CRATERING TO AN ALL-TIME LOW,
INFLATION RAMPING UP WITH PRICES
SURGING AND NOW ADD THE JOBS
DISASTER TO THE LIST.
IT'S THE WORST JOBS REPORT OF
HIS PRESIDENCY SO FAR.
DON'T WORRY.
BIDEN SAYS HE'S MAKING REAL
PROGRESS.
>> TODAY'S REPORT AS THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE DOWN TO 4.8%.
A SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT FROM
WHEN I TOOK OFFICE.
THE MONTHLY TOTAL HAS BOUNCED
AROUND.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE TREND,
IT'S SOLID.
THINGS IN WASHINGTON, AS YOU
KNOW, ARE NOISY.
TURN ON THE NOISE, EVERY
CONVERSATION IS A CONFRONTATION.
EVERY DISAGREEMENT IS A CRISIS.
WHEN YOU TAKE A STEP BACK, LOOK
AT WHAT IS HAPPENING, WE'RE
ACTUALLY MAKING REAL PROGRESS.
DOESN'T SEEM FAST ENOUGH.
I WOULD LIKE IT FASTER.
WE'RE MAKING CONSISTENT STEADY
PROGRESS.
>> YESTERDAY BIDEN WAS BRAGGING
ABOUT THE UNVAXED BEING FIRED.
>> MORE LIVES ARE BEING SAVED.
LET'S BE CLEAR, WHEN YOU SEE
HEADLINES AND REPORTS OF MASS
FIRINGS AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR JOBS, LOOK AT THE
BIGGER STORY.
>> SO HE'S SAYING IT'S GOOD
UNVAXED AMERICANS WERE LAID OFF.
KENNEDY, THE RECOVERY IS
STALLING.
THAT'S CLEAR.
IT WAS A V AND STARTED TO FADE.
THERE'S MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
JOBS STILL OPEN, ABOUT 11
MILLION AND AMERICANS ARE NOT
TRYING TO FILL THEM.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CAN'T MAKE
SENSE OF IT.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS,
THEY'RE BEING DISINGENUOUS.
IT'S OKAY TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
THAT SOMETIMES THINGS ARE NOT
GREAT. GOING
GREAT AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION, A LOT OF THINGS
ARE GOING WRONG AND THAT IS
SHOWING UP IN THE POLLS.
OF THE QUINNIPIAC POLL, EVERY
SINGLE MEASURE, THE PRESIDENT IS
UNDERWATER.
AFGHANISTAN, IMMIGRATION,
TAXATION, INFLATION, IT'S ALL
BAD FOR HIM AND THINGS LIKE
INFLATION, THAT IS NOT GETTING
BETTER ANYTIME SOON.
EVEN THE FED WHICH IS DOING THE
SAME THING THE WHITE HOUSE DOES,
WHICH IS TRY TO PAINT THIS
SHORT-TERM ROSY PICTURE, NOW
THEY HAVE TO ADMIT IT IS A
LONG-TERM PROBLEM AND I GET
REALLY SICK OF SITTING THROUGH
BRIEFINGS FROM THE PRESIDENT AND
JEN PSAKI AND THE COMMUNICATIONS
TEAM WHERE THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY
LYING TO PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: WHAT ABOUT WHAT YOU
SAID, IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WHY
DOESN'T THE PRESIDENT SAY
LISTEN, YOU SLOWED IT DOWN,
HERE'S WHAT I'M GOING TO DO TO
ADDRESS IT, BE PATIENT, SPINS
AND LIES AND THAT IS WHY PEOPLE
DON'T TRUST THEM.
>> Richard: I TEND TO AGREE
WITH KENNEDY.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE COULD
HAVE SAID THIS IS NOT THE BEST
JOBS REPORT AND THAT SPEAKS TO
WHY WE NEED TO BUILD BACK BETTER
PLAN.
HE COULD HAVE MADE UP OF IT, THE
ONE THING WE SAW THIS JOBS
REPORT WITH A LOT OF THE LOSSES
OF JOBS WERE TWO WOMEN.
A LOT OF WOMEN LOST JOBS WHICH
SPEAKS TO THE FACT THAT A LOT OF
WOMEN AREN'T GOING BACK TO WORK,
THEY HAVE CHILD CARE ISSUES, A
LOT OF WOMEN AREN'T GOING TO
WORK BECAUSE OF WAGE ISSUES.
ALL THE THINGS BIDEN TALKED
ABOUT OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN THE
BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN.
IT'S NOT GOING WELL BUT WHEN WE
PASS THIS PLAN, WOMEN WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOME HELP WHEN IT
COMES TO PAYING FOR CHILD CARE.
THEY CAN BE BACK TO WORK, BACK
IN THE OFFICES AND THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT PAYING THE
MORTGAGE THAT IS NOW EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION FOR MANY
FAMILIES.
I WANT TO BIDEN TO REALLY TALK
ABOUT HOW HIS AGENDA IS AND HOW
TO MOVE THE WHOLE COUNTRY
FORWARD, NOT JUST DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: SAYING AN AGREEMENT
THAT WOMEN WERE HAPPY WHEN THEY
WERE NOT COMING BACK AND THEY
HAD STAYED HOME.
>> Greg: I WISH YOU HAD KEPT
THAT PRIVATE, BUT NOW EVERYBODY
KNOWS WHAT A SEXIST PIG I AM.
IF THE NUMBERS WERE REALLY IN
THE TOILET, MAYBE ACTIVISTS
WOULD FORM A LINE OUTSIDE TO
TALK TO HIM.
IT'S FRIDAY, I DON'T CARE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF JOE FACED THE
SAME SCRUTINY THAT TRUMPED IT?
OR OF TRUMP FACED THE SAME
SCRUTINY AS JOE BIDEN DID?
HE COULD EITHER BE THE GREATEST
PRESIDENT THAT EVER LIVED IF HE
HAD THE JOE TREATMENT AND JOE
WOULD BE THE WORST PRESIDENT
THAT EVER LIVED IF HE GOT THE
TRUMP TREATMENT.
I FIND THAT HIGHLY INTERESTING,
I THINK.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN IN POLITICS
FOR OVER HALF A CENTURY AND HE
SUCKS.
SO THIS ISN'T REALLY A COMMENT
ON BIDEN.
IT TELLS YOU THAT POLITICS, THE
LONGER YOU ARE IN IT, THE
EXPERIENCE DOESN'T IMPROVE YOUR
COMPETENCE.
IN FACT, IT MIGHT BE THE
REVERSE.
>> Jesse: LOOK AT FAUCI, THEY
ARE FOREVER.
>> Greg: THIS COULD BE THE
CONDITION WHERE THE MORE YOU ARE
IN SOMETHING, THE WORSE YOU
BECOME.
WHEN YOU COMPARE TRUMP, WHO WAS
NEVER IN POLITICS, WHO DID MORE
IN A YEAR, NO POLITICAL
EXPERIENCE.
LOVE HIM OR HATE HIM,
EMOTIONALLY, HE HURTS ME SO
MUCH.
HE DID A LOT.
WE TALKED ABOUT NORTH KOREA IN A
WHILE?
THE FACT IS BIDEN HAS BEEN
AROUND FOREVER.
HE'S TERRIBLE, AWFUL BUT LOOK AT
A LOT OF PEOPLE, IT'S NOT JUST
HIM, IT IS KERRY AS WELL, IT IS
FAUCI, IT IS PELOSI.
THE LONGER PEOPLE ARE IN THIS
MACHINE THE WORSE IT IS, MAYBE
WE STOP ELECTING THESE LIFERS.
FORCE THEM OUT.
>> Jesse: AND WE BLAME
EVERYTHING ON COVID.
>> THE COVID EXCUSE WAS STILL
THERE.
I WANT TO DO A SERVICE TO OUR
VIEWERS AND SAY, I WAS JUST
CHATTING WITH LARRY KUDLOW AND
PROBABLY HE WOULD TAKE EVERY
REASON TO CRITICIZE THIS JOB
REPORT, THERE WERE ACTUALLY SOME
REALLY NOTABLE GAINS IN THE JOBS
REPORT WE SHOULD HIGHLIGHT.
THE BIG DROP THAT HELD BACK THE
BIG JOB GROWTH NUMBERS WAS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT EDUCATION JOBS
FELL 144,000.
THERE WERE GAINS.
PEOPLE GOING BACK INTO LEISURE
AND HOSPITALITY COME AGAIN IN
ENTERTAINMENT, THE RECREATION
CENTER.
SOME NOTABLE GAINS, THEY GO UP,
I DON'T WANT TO --
>> Greg: ARE THE GAMES WHEN
YOU ARE JUST GOING BACK TO WHAT
WAS THERE?
>> Sandra: THE POINT IS THE
LOSS IS MORE SEEN AS SEASONAL.
THAT BEING SAID, TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT MESSAGING, WHEN I SAW
BIDEN SPEAKING AT THE PODIUM
TODAY, OBVIOUSLY, THERE WASN'T A
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A
VICTORY LAP, BUT THE MESSAGING
AND THE ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE
REALITY OF THE SITUATION WHEN IT
COMES TO INFLATION, HE IS
PULLING THE HORRIBLY WHEN IT
COMES TO INFLATION, PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO SPEND MORE AND
ABSOLUTELY EVERYTHING, A MAJOR
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS RIGHT NOW
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO OUR LOCAL
PHARMACIES AND GROCERY STORES
AND THEY DON'T HAVE OUR BASIC
NEEDS.
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM THAT HAS
TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU ARE NOT SEEING THAT HAPPEN
BUT THE OTHER THING IS, AFTER
THE JOBS REPORT, HE USED THAT
SPEECH TO TALK A LOT ABOUT INTO
PAGES INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE AS
A WAY TO GET BACK TO WORK.
FINE, TAKE AN UP OR DOWN VOTE ON
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IF THAT
IS THE KEY TO GETTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK.
WHY DIDN'T HE ASK CONGRESS TO DO
THAT?
>> Jesse: BUT HE CAN'T BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOW ON A TWO TRACK.
IF THEY VOTE FOR THE 1.5
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY ARE PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO GO FOR THE
3.5 TRILLION.
>> Kennedy: BUT AT LEAST THE
PRESIDENT GETS A WIN.
THEY NEED IT DESPERATELY GIVEN
THESE POLL NUMBERS.
HORRIBLE POLITICS ALL THE WAY
AROUND.
IT WILL B